ne pensez-vous pas que nous allons trop loin
non ce saut de couverture vous n'êtes pas un perdant
ne m'appelez pas comme ça d'
accord et c'est là que nous obtenons des glaces gratuites
vraiment ouais ouais nous avons de l'argent est-ce que
nous en avons assez
excusez-moi  excusez-moi mademoiselle pourriez-vous nous donner de la
monnaie s'il vous plaît nous avons besoin de votre
glace parce que nous n'avons pas d'
argent nous avons cinq cents ouais nous avons juste
mon ami le médecin a dit nous en avons
un nous devons manger de la glace tout de suite
ouais mon  docteur je suis vraiment star nous ne sommes pas à
moi
ça va merci beaucoup cette
grande fille se
sent comme ta nuit veux voir le patron
ouais
toi